The fourth and final part of Netflix's Sabrina
is a veritable Pandora's box of Eldritch terrors
and OG aunties with an intensely emotional
ending that will have many fans wishing for
another season.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm breaking down the series finale
of CAOS,
clues and theories about what would have happened
in the now-cancelled Part 5, and whether Sabrina
could still return.
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care.
The main events of the finale kick off when
Sabrina Morningstar crashes through the magic
mirror as she returns from the duplicate cosmos.
Having fled the alternate Earth with a talking
Salem who's actually an Eldritch terror himself,
she arrives back in Sabrina Spellman's bedroom
and warns her that the Void is on its way
to destroy the Earth.
But Morningstar's escape and journey between
the two worlds has left her badly injured
and she and Salem quickly die.
In an effort to stop the Void, Sabrina Spellman
is about to make a wish on the reality-altering
Imp of the Perverse when the mysterious trinket
salesman shows up.
Sabrina trades the Imp for Pandora's Box,
the mythical object said to have unleashed
evil and terror into the world.
Sabrina using Pandora's fabled box against
the Eldritch terrors which Blackwood summoned
is a nice call-back to Part 2 when she taunted
him about her newfound powers to resurrect
and perform miracles.
"The gods give Pandora a jar containing all
the sorrows of the world.
They armed her for vengeance, Father Blackwood.
For destruction.
Do you really want to open that lid?"
Sabrina then ventures into the Void alone
and, as she wants to take full responsibility
for the impending apocalypse, she blocks off
the magic mirror so no one can follow her.
Given that the Void by definition represents
nothingness, the design the CAOS team came
up with is interesting.
The pictures in the room are by the renowned
Dutch graphic artist M.C.
Escher who was known for his depictions of
mathematical and impossible objects.
For example, when you look at this pair-of-hands
drawing, the image creates a strange illusionary
loop in your mind so you can't tell where
the picture begins or ends.
And it seems like a fitting choice perhaps
given that it was Sabrina's refusal to go
back and complete the time loop at the end
of Part 3 which led to this situation in the
first place.
"When you're done with everything you have
to come back to right here, right now, and
do what I just did to complete the time loop.
It's the only way to keep the realms preserved."
Another intriguing piece of Escher's art in
the Void is "Day and Night", with its symmetrical
mirroring of dark and light birds flying in
opposite directions that merge into a patchwork
of tiled fields below.
This piece seems to perfectly represent Sabrina's
dual nature with her mortal and infernal sides
as well as the merging of the two different
but same Sabrinas this season.
Now that she's in the Void, Sabrina opens
up Pandora's Box which starts sucking the
final Eldritch terror into it.
But this time it's not her impetuousness that
messes up the plan as it's often done in the
past;
instead, back on Earth, her aunties, Ambrose
and Nick have cast a spell that brings Spellman's
soul back into Morningstar's dead body.
And although the Void appears to have been
defeated when they discover it's disappeared
from the Academy's Observatory, weird things
begin to happen the next day.
It's Sabrina's 17th birthday, one year on
from the events of the first season, and objects
and even people start to mysteriously disappear
around her.
A scan reveals that Sabrina's insides appear
empty and they realise that the Void is now
inside her.
Understanding that she's a threat to everyone
and everything around her, Sabrina selflessly
banishes herself to the Mountains of Madness
to protect those she loves.
Blackwood, who knows the Void's arrived, seeks
out Sabrina with the intention of sacrificing
her by draining out the Eldritch terror,
then containing it and consuming it to obtain
its powers, similar to when he ate a piece
of the Uninvited.
Team Spellman goes to the Mountains of Madness
for a final showdown with Blackwood and the
Void, during which Faustus is neutralised
after they trick him with a fake Pandora's
Box, blinding him with gunpowder.
However, Sabrina, who's been learning everything
about the Void, explains that Blackwood's
plan to blood-let her is still the only way
to extract the Eldritch terror from inside
her.
And although she and her aunties fear the
worst, she shows strength, leadership and
bravery in her final moments.
"The Void believes in nothing, thinks we don't
matter.
But we do.
We have a strength and a bond that the Void
can't touch.
So let's finish this the way we always do...
together."
It's a very emotional moment given the risks
and even a little Iron Man Endgame-esque.
And just before they begin, there's a little
bit of foreshadowing of how Nick will end
up joining Sabrina in the afterlife.
"I'll see you on the other side."
As the white Void flows out of Sabrina, she
tries to hold on but it just takes too long,
and in her final moments she says goodbye
to everyone as a montage flashes past.
It's a heart-breaking time for Nick especially
when he emerges last from the Void to tell
Sabrina they saved everyone, only to learn
she's dead.
Nick and Sabrina, of course, do end up together
in the very final scene of the series as he
joins her in the "The Sweet Hereafter", revealing
that he went swimming in the Sea of Sorrows
and drowned.
Whether he meant that literally or figuratively,
it seems that Nick was determined to be with
Sabrina and decided to join her in the afterlife.
"Sabrina Spellman...
we're end-game."
That's similar to what Sabrina told Harvey
in Part 3 about him and Roz who also end up
together by the end of the series.
"You guys are endgame."
A couple of interesting details are that Sabrina
now has a white headband rather than the black
or red ones we've seen her with.
And as Nick and Sabrina kiss, he pulls her
hand to the chain around his neck that holds
his locket, the other one of which he gave
her for her 17th birthday.
"One for me...
and one for you.
So that I'll always be able to find you."
A few other moments foreshadowing this scene
include when Nick told Sabrina that he wanted
to be a part of her world.
"Calm down Ariel."
And also as Sabrina is dying you can hear
a little echo of her telling Nick
"I'm never letting you go."
That's something Sabrina said to Nick in Part
3 after he returned to her from being trapped
with Lucifer in the Acheron.
"I'm never letting you go."
And although I have mixed feelings about this
final scene and how the series ended, it's
worth noting that Sabrina looks happy and
at peace with herself even before Nick arrives.
That's because Sabrina learning to love herself
was a big theme in Part 4.
"We will always be loved.
We have each other, and we love each other."
Then there was that great moment when the
two Sabrinas just hung out and had fun dancing
with each other.
We also see how Sabrina comes to understand
that although she can have a boyfriend if
she chooses, she doesn't absolutely need one
to be happy.
"Who needs boys when we have each other?"
Amusingly though, Spellman does have a go
at making her own ideal man by using the candle
she inscribed with Nick and Harvey's names
in Part 3.
"May you be the best of both Nick and Harvey."
And although things don't exactly work out
with Lucas Hunt, Sabrina quickly moves on
from the brief fling and flushes the wax man
down the drain.
"Boys.
I think I need to be alone for a little while.
I need to figure out who I am."
It's great to see Sabrina maturing in this
way in her final season
as it's been something of an intentional running
joke through the series about how she often
ploughs ahead doing exactly the opposite of
what everyone else is recommending.
This criticism has been a little unfair at
times, given she's only young and will naturally
want to do her own thing, and be curious,
rebellious, and even foolhardy at times.
And despite a few stumbles such as getting
drunk and causing a scene at Hilda's wedding,
by the time the Eldritch terror the Cosmic
arrives on the horizon, Sabrina and her doppelganger
decide to step up to the plate and take full
accountability.
"This mess is our fault.
We won't be responsible for countless deaths
of witches, mortals, and infernals."
The idea that Sabrina's reckless decisions
would culminate in a grand reckoning was mentioned
way back in Part 2 by her aunt Hilda.
"You better brace yourself, girl, because
everything has a price.
That's how witchcraft works."
"But I don't think there's a price for me."
"Huh?"
"Not anymore."
"You are racking up a cosmic debt the like
of which the world's never seen."
Owning up to the problem, both Sabrinas agree
to a risky merge procedure that will cause
at least one of them to lose their memories
and identity, a neat call-back to when Sabrina
intercepted herself at the end of Part 3.
"Shouldn't we merge or something?"
"Ambrose would say so, yes, but I have a supes
crazy idea."
I like the way this scene is framed, with
the twins lying next to each other on a stone
slab, with Sabrina Morningstar on the left
and Spellman on the right,
referencing the dream that Sabrina had in
the very first episode of Season 1 when she
came across a pair of baby twins on a large
stone in the woods, and the baby on the left
had hooved feet like the Devil.
And although that merge is abandoned, in a
sense both Sabrinas do end up merged in the
end when Spellman's soul is transferred into
Morningstar's body.
Because the series was cancelled after filming
for Part 4 had been completed,
there are some big plot points and character
arcs that were left wide open to explore in
what would have been the next season.
Lilith had an especially traumatic time in
Part 4, with Caliban first cursing her pregnant
belly to explode which almost killed her,
and then Lucifer threatening to take away
her son.
"As Romulus and Remus suckled on the teat
of a wolf, so our son shall suckle on the
teat of a hellhound.
You have six last hours to spend with Adam."
In a desperate act, rather than hand her baby
over to the Dark Lord, she kills him and serves
him as a meal,
which also serves as revenge for when Lucifer
killed Mary Wardwell's fiancé Adam in the
second season and cooked him as a dinner for
Lilith.
Enraged, Lucifer strips Lilith of her powers
and inflicts her with human weakness but the
inability to die.
So, she asks Caliban to get her the Spear
of Longinus so she can kill herself;
but after Zelda convinces her not to throw
her life away, she uses it to stab Lucifer
after he reneges on a deal to restore her
abilities.
It's a gruesome but powerful moment when she
consumes his celestial blood and powers.
With Lucifer cast out of Hell and Caliban
stuck in the Void, the season ends with Madame
Satan back in charge of the infernal realm,
and it would have been fascinating to see
what she would have got up to in Part 5.
The series' long-running villain Father Blackwood
is finally defeated by the very end, as Prudence
chops him up into tiny pieces to scatter across
the world.
Even with his immortality, it would be highly
unlikely he'd ever re-form his body again.
However, continuing his work is Ms Wardwell
who we see reading the Eldritch Gospel to
the Pilgrims of the Night Church and recounting
the events of the final episode.
So a fifth season could have brought her back
as a potential antagonist.
There were also numerous pointers to a war
brewing throughout Part 4, with a few scenes
showing that the denizens of Hell were unhappy
with the Greendale coven's worship of the
goddess Hecate.
"The witches are without the Dark Lord's gifts.
They now worship Hecate.
They mean war."
And we know from showrunner Roberto Aguirre-Sacasa
that Part 5 was originally going to deal with
what he called a "Witch War".
I also expect that originally Sabrina's death
in Part 4 wasn't going to be permanent and
would have been reversed in some way.
In fact, there's a line that Zelda says to
Hilda after burying both the Sabrinas that
seems to hint at this.
"Why did you not preserve her, Dark Mother?
It's not right, Hilda.
It's just not right that she's gone."
Zelda is referring to Hecate, and how they
all prayed to her during Sabrina's bloodletting
to keep her alive.
We've already seen how Hecate has been able
to bring the dead back to life in the series,
for instance Hilda in Part 3,
which makes me wonder whether there was originally
an alternate ending that at least hinted at
Sabrina's return?
Perhaps the original final scene was just
a flicker of life from Sabrina's grave, à
la Batman v Superman?
Or whether that would have just been seen
at the start of Part 5?
Of course, in a supernatural world like CAOS
anything can happen, and even the showrunner
has hinted that there could be something still
to come after Part 4,
although whether this is just the promised
comic book follow-up or a spin-off, prequel,
or crossover in Riverdale remains to be seen.
And if you haven't had enough Sabrina yet,
you can discover more of the amazing details
and easter eggs cleverly hidden in the show
in my CAOS Things You Missed video.
Tap here to watch that or follow the link
in the video description.
So, what were your thoughts on the fourth
and final season of Chilling Adventures?
Were you happy with the ending or what else
would you have liked to see?
Leave your comments below!
And if you enjoyed this, don't forget to leave
a thumbs-up, it's hugely appreciated.
Now tap left for my next Sabrina video or
tap right for something else you're sure to
like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!